bonjour à tous donc je suis
effectivement designer et je vais vous
parler un peu de ce métier méconnu qui
pourraient pour autant nous aider un
corps dire venir en aide à une de nos
vieilles malade qui est la démocratie
donc aussi moins que je me souviens
quand j'étais petit je voulais être
inventeur j'ai fini designer c'est pas
si mal que ça et lorsque j'ai dû faire
le choix dans mes études j'ai longtemps
hésité entre les sciences politiques et
le design je vais pas vous spoiler la
femme et vous aurez deviné que je vais
manger plutôt d'un côté ou d'un autre et
pourtant il y avait une espèce de petite
frustration qui s'était laissé en moi
d'avoir choisi le design plutôt que les
sciences politiques et lorsque je parle
design alors je voudrais revenir un peu
sur ce que fait un designer et qu'on
soit d'accord un designer s'est pas
forcément ça c'est pas forcément un
barbu un peu excentrique c'est pas
forcément un décorateur un artiste ou un
styliste un designer quand je parle de
design ce sera plutôt du design
industriel une personne qui va venir
assemblée des contextes des publics des
problématiques ensemble pour essayer de
créer des objets des produits des
espaces qu'ils vont répondre à des
besoins qui prendra une esthétique assez
assez développé et tous ces éléments que
moi j'ai pu acquérir en tant que
designer m'ont servi après
servi après dans dans ce que j'ai essayé
de porter pour la démocratie donc en
tant que designer jacky un certain
nombre d'outils et notamment quelque
chose qu'on appelle à penser design par
le design thinking aussi en anglais et
c'est un état d'esprit en fait qui fait
que vous allez à la fois croisé des
choses qui tiennent d'une analyse
objective donc on a des études des
chiffres des choses très carré est
également des choses plus subjectif qui
sont de l'ordre du ressenti de l'émotion
que peuvent avoir les utilisateurs avec
qui vous travaillez et pour capter ces
émotions on va notamment aller voir ses
utilisateurs vont aller leur parler on
va aller les rencontrer quel que soit
leur âge ont essayé de voir de quoi ils
ont besoin qu'est ce qui leur fait peur
qu'est ce qui les motive et on va
brasser toutes ces informations tout ce
qu'on a appris avec une sacrée dose de
créativité et notre métier en plus à
cette spécificité que moi dire que
d'autres métiers peut aussi trouver des
idées essayer de résoudre des problèmes
mais on essaye de représenter ses idées
de leur donner de la chair de leur
donner du corps et de pouvoir les
communiqués de cette de cette manière et
au fur et à mesure que j'ai avancé on va
dire dans mon parcours de designers je
me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de petites choses que
j'avais abordé alors c'était la question
des interactions entre les personnes la
question de penser en système
l'intérêt pour les sciences sociales et
je me rendais compte qu'en fait il ya
pas mal de convergence avec tout ce qui
était les sciences politiques que
j'avais laissé un peu de côté du coup
dans mon parcours d'études et sans
savoir d'une certaine manière j'avais
commencé
à m'intéresser à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler en fait le design des politiques
publiques en tant que designer il faut
le savoir aussi j'ai un amour
inconditionnel pour les post it je sais
pas si vous êtes déjà entré dans le
bureau d'un designer mais on fait la
tapisserie avec avec des post it et au
delà de la petite anecdote
quand j'ai vraiment commencé à apprendre
un peu conscience que j'étais pas tout à
fait dans le design
industrielle classique je me suis rendu
compte que j'étais dans une mouvance si
on peut parler de violence un peu plus
large qui était celle du design sociale
qui s'intéressait justement à essayer de
résoudre des problèmes que pourraient
rencontrer le monde et non pas
uniquement des problèmes économiques et
chemin faisant j'ai continué à
travailler un peu sur la question à
travers des projets personnels à travers
des projets aussi en école ou alors que
ce soit des projets professionnels et
malgré une première expérimentation de
croiser les sciences politiques avec mes
compétences de design ça a été fait de
bouc alors fait boucle il faut se
replacer dans le contexte on est en 2008
c'est la première année du quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy c'est sa période un peu
bling bling et en même temps on à
facebook qui arrive en france et les
gens commencent à se montrer donc on
espèces d'analogie entre les politiques
qui se met beaucoup en avant qui met
beaucoup leur vie en avant et les gens
qui font la même chose donc on a
commencé à raconter
l'actualité politique française sous
forme de news facebook à se donner des
choses comme un certain nicolas s peut
être ami avec rolex par exemple et on
avait cette espèce de façon de raconter
l'actualité politique française qui
était un peu satirique qui a commencé à
pas mal plaire alors ça pas plu à tout
le monde on a eu tous avocats de
facebook qui ont pas trop coûté à la
blague et qui nous ont fait savoir mais
ce qui a été intéressant au delà de
bâtir de toutes les aventures c'est que
pour moi c'était la première fois que je
croise et mes compétences designer avec
cet intérêt pour la politique et surtout
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
quelque chose à creuser dans ce sens là
simplement que quand je parlais avec des
gens qui allaient voir facebook etc je
me rendais compte qu'ils avaient
commencé à s'intéresser à la politique
par ce biais là parce que l'école avait
été détourné parce qu on leur parlait de
politique d'une façon différente alors
qu'il se serait pas forcément intéressé
à la politique autrement donc je
commençais aussi avoir métier d'une
façon un peu différente c'est à dire que
ce n'était pas uniquement un métier
j'allais pouvoir faire un engagement
citoyen j'allais pouvoir
on va dire participer au débat public
aux principes et à la chose publique
sans pour autant faire partie d'un parti
politique ou adhérer à une association
et donc c'est un élément qui m'a poussé
en fait à reconsidérer j'avais quasiment
mon titre professionnel pour parler de
design des choses publiques donc des
choses qui allaient toucher notamment à
la démocratie et ça m'a poussé aussi à
me demander quelles compétences au final
en tant que designer que j'ai acquise
qui est compétent je peux mettre au
service de cette chose publique au
service de cette démocratie et la
réponse la première réponse était
d'essayer de résoudre les problèmes qui
pourraient se poser aujourd'hui
un designer qui a pris fin qui approche
une question aussi complexe que peut
l'être la chose publique ou la
démocratie
c'est avant tout porter un autre regard
sur sur 7 sur cette matière là c'est à
dire que vous avez pas mal de
sociologues qui étudient la question
vous avez des anthropologues mais nous
on a un regard un peu différent parce
qu'on va s'intéresser à comment les gens
pratiquent cette démocratie comment les
gens l'utilisent la consomment parfois
de manière pas très glamour parfois de
manière un peu un peu détournée est ce
que peut y voir le designer en observant
la démocratie c'est notamment des
nouveaux comportements c'est à dire
qu'on a des gens entre l'individualisme
et co opération opportuniste on a de
nouveau besoin de nouvelles attentes par
exemple j'ai besoin qu'on me donne un
retour sur ma participation à telle
réunion où j'ai besoin de pouvoir
m'engager sans pour autant être membre
d'un parti politique et le designer va
aussi s'intéresser à comment les
technologies en fait vont pouvoir venir
modifier
le rapport qu'on a la démocratie c'est à
dire qu'avec internet et notamment les
tout ce qui est technologies numériques
les enjeux change à peu c'est à dire qu
on est sur des questions de
confidentialité on est question sont des
questions d'instantanéité on est sur des
questions que de l'intelligence
collective et tout ce brassage à la fois
de d'opportunités et de menaces est un
peu une sorte de matériaux bruts pour le
designer sur lequel ils peuvent venir
travailler donc le designer il a tout un
panel d'outils de méthode pour
intervenir justement sur une question
aussi complexe que la démocratie avec
des enjeux aussi divers et variés et un
de ses premiers volets sais ce dont je
parle est à l'heure à savoir l' approche
centrée sur l'utilisateur c'est un gros
gros mot mais ça veut surtout dire qu'on
va les voir de quoi ont besoin les gens
et qu'est ce qui peut les motiver
c'est une question que j'ai abordés
notamment avec alain un site qui
s'appelle influents et influent l'idée
est partie du fait que je parlais avec
des gens je faisais mes titres recherche
etc pour voir pourquoi il ne
s'engagerait pas dans la démocratie et
il y avait quelque chose qui revenait
régulièrement c'était oui mais moi ma
parole mon avis mon opinion elle a pas
de poids elle ne pèse rien dans la
démocratie a le ps rien dans la prise de
décision et c'était tout le but enfin
tout le but toute idée d' influence
était justement de montrer qu' il
pouvait y avoir un poids mais aussi
qu'on pouvait le développer j'avais créé
une plateforme qui permettait justement
de calcul est entre guillemets sa portée
et son influence citoyenne et de la
développer ensuite en participant à des
événements en s'impliquant dans sa ville
et faisant ça en fait je venais gratter
aussi quelque chose qui était un peu
tabou dans la politique qui est inhérent
mais qui est tabou qui était la question
de lego et la question de l' influence
donc encore une fois ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est très glamour ça
n'est pas quelque chose
qu'une autre discipline qui
s'intéresserait à la démocratie
viendrait chercher mais nous on avait
quelque chose qui était de l'ordre du
besoin réel et la réalité n'est pas
forcément toujours très rose donc tu es
venu taper dans cette question de lego
pour influent mais construit avec les
publics
compteront pour les publics
c'est un volet du travail du designer
l'autre volet c'est de construire avec
le public autrement dit on va venir
embarquer les gens dans l'aventuré pour
les aider à concevoir une nouvelle
démocratie on a fait ça notamment en
mars dernier au cours des élections
municipales on a monté un truc qui
s'appelle l'atelier des élections et on
a proposé aux gens de venir construire
leurs propres outils pour décrypter et
participer aux élections municipales
alors on a eu plein d'outils qui sont
qui sont ressortis on avait des
comparateurs de programme on avait des
jeux de cette famille par exemple pour
apprendre à connaître les candidats donc
on avait une façon de il y avait une
façon pour les citoyens de s'exprimer
sur cette question de la politique la
question des élections qui était
différente qui était de passer par par
le faire en fait et c'est une démarche
qu'on a ensuite reproduits sur des
ateliers qui s'appelle l'atelier de la
gouvernance où là on essaye de proposer
aux citoyens
des formats de réflexion et des formats
de production pour qu'ils imaginent la
ville de nantes plus participative plus
transparents et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en faisant avec ses publics en
les mettant en capacité de faire eh ben
on a des gens qui ne seraient pas venues
à des réunions publiques qui n'aurait
pas été intéressé par cette chose qui
nous rejoignent et qui s'engagent de
cette manière
construire c'est un peu donc la base du
design réfléchi sert beaucoup mais on
fait aussi beaucoup et il ya un outil
qu'on adore c'est le prototypage rapide
le prototypage rapide c'est à dire qu'on
essaye des choses très très vite on va
les modifier on va se gamelle et
plusieurs fois on va itérer on va
essayer plusieurs versions et c'est
notamment ce qu'on a fait avec cette
petite ce petit comptoir qu'on appelait
le débat mobile ou pour faire du débat
public plutôt que de rester cloisonné
dans une réunion publique dans une salle
où il ya toujours les mêmes personnes
qui viennent nous autres on a décidé
d'aller au devant des gens donc on a
conçu un machin qui se déploie ça fait
un peu comptoir de bar et les gens
pendant qu'ils faisaient leur marché
pourrait prendre cinq minutes
s'intéresser aux projets qui étaient mis
en débat sur les éoliennes au large de
saint nazaire prendre un petit café
discuter laisser un avis et on avait en
fait une sorte de
dire de démocratie vraiment de proximité
et là où c'était intéressant cette idée
de prototypage rapide de construire est
d'essayer on a essayé plein de defour
n'a en fait d'arriver à la avant
d'arriver à la forme finale et selon les
publics selon les endroits on allait
s'installer on n'avait pas la même
expérience c'est à dire que si vous
alliez dans un lycée la façon dont vous
allez organiser vous allez design est
entre guillemets le le débat ne se
passait pas de la même façon donc essayé
plusieurs fois et c'est plein de petites
choses voilà qu'elle marche c'est
quelque chose que peut se permettre aux
designers pas forcément toujours se
permettre le politique et qui permet
d'avancer bien plus vite sur des
questions assez complexe et le design
c'est aussi pas mal de créativité ce qui
veut dire qu'on peut se permettre des
formats un peu originaux je pense
notamment aux news games qui a une
thématique sur laquelle je travaille en
ce moment qui en fait on a créé des jeux
vidéo donc
type un peu serious game pour les quais
pour les plus gamer d'entre vous mais
qui croise des codes journalistique
c'est à dire qu'on va s'intéresser à des
sujets de société des sujets de
controverse par exemple gaz de schiste
et on va essayer de mettre le joueur en
position de s'informer d'expérimenter
voire même de s'engager dans une cause
en jouant à ce jeu donc ce sont des jeux
qui portent des messages assez fort avec
gem gaz par exemple on avait le parti
pris de décrypter les tactiques de
lobbying des globules du groupe prg au
gaz de schiste
mais le problème avec toute cette
jaillir tout ce panel d'outils pour
résoudre candidats pour résoudre les
problème c'est qu'en soit la résolution
de problèmes à ses propres problèmes et
à ses propres limites et on est souvent
pris en tant que designer dans les
contraintes économiques qu'on fasse des
choses qui rapportent de l'argent on est
aussi soumis à tous qui sait tout ce qui
est les règles de la société de
consommation et surtout on est dans une
approche qui est très court termiste un
peu comme le politique d'ailleurs on
fait des choses à deux trois quatre cinq
ans mais on a du mal à se projeter sur
le plus long terme et c'est face à ces
limites que j'essayais de revoir un peu
la pratique que j'avais du design des
choses publiques de design de démocratie
et je suis passé de résoudre les
problèmes d'aujourd'hui en fait a plutôt
essayé d'anticiper les problèmes de
demain parce que il y avait une espèce
de attitude réflexive en fait sur ce que
je faisais en tant qu en tant que
designer c'est à dire que certes bon bah
je pouvais pas résoudre tous les
problèmes et il y avait toujours ce
problème du court termisme mais surtout
je voulais savoir quel impact j'allais
avoir un long terme en créant certains
dispositifs et surtout quels défis
j'aurais potentiellement à relever
demain
donc cette idée du décès d'anticiper les
problèmes gelé d'abord traiter avec
quelque chose qui s'appelle le design
critiques dont qui est une forme de
design qu'on pourrait dire pour
déconstruire les réalités autrement dit
on va venir construire des choses les
objets des espaces qu'ils vont poser des
questions sur des sujets de controverse
autrement dit on va essayer d'enrichir
le débat public en faisant réagir les
gens sur des objets un peu provocant qui
vont les questionner sur des thématiques
aussi complexes que des technologies
émergentes des publics
invisible à qui on donne pas la parole
et s'est notamment quelque chose que
j'ai fait avec un projet qui s'appelle
ap il est ce qui était une
espèce de scénario un peu caustique un
peu critique sur la recherche du bonheur
dans les villes connectés et ça servait
à près de matière à discussion de
matières ou débat à enrichir on va dire
les opinions des gens dans le sens où vu
qu'ils étaient un peu titillé par une
part quelque chose de concret c'était
beaucoup plus facile pour eux de réagir
et de se projeter donc la dimension
critique du design est assez
intéressante pour révéler un certain
nombre on va garder le statu quo qui
existent dans la société qui l'empêchent
d'avancer dizaine donné quasiment un
pansement la psychothérapie
psychothérapie pour la société mais
critiquer ne fait pas tout on a aussi
besoin aujourd'hui d'imaginer de rêver
de se projeter sur qu'est ce que
pourrait être qu'est ce que pourrait
être la démocratie ou qu'est ce que
pourrait être le royaume public demain
et c'est quelque chose que permet une
autre forme de design qui le design
spéculatifs donc on va dire spéculer à
la manière des bourses ou autre mais on
va venir essayer de se projeter
d'extrapoler des choses qui existent
déjà aujourd'hui est de voir comment
demain elle pourrait s'incarner dans le
monde en fait c'est ont fait un peu le
travail qu'ont pu faire certains
écrivains en termes d'utopie outre ce
qu'on passe à des utopies concrètes
c'est à dire que c'est aussi le rôle du
designer c'est de concevoir des choses
de les représenter de manière tangible
pour permettre aux jambes a décidé est
ce que c'est ce futur là que je veux ou
est ce que c'est un autre notre futur et
ce travail de design spéculatifs je
l'abordé notamment autour de la question
la smart cities donc vous avez peut-être
entendu parler tout ce qui est la vie
connectée et pour traiter cette question
de la smart city 2 quelle fut dans
quelle ville dans le futur on va vivre
je l'abordé du point de vue des animaux
parce que les animaux sont totalement
oubliés dans le futur il faut imaginer
qu'il ya plus du tout d'animaux dans les
smart city est donc en mettant l'animal
au coeur de la smart cities à la place
de l'humain ça permettait justement
encore une fois de réagir de faire
réagir d'essayer de créer la discussion
avec les publics qui pourraient être
concernés en l'occurrence ici les
promoteurs de de la smart cities est
d'essayer de les faire on va dire
s'exprimer sur certains points de
friction certaines zones grises qui
existaient dedans
mais que ce soit avec le design
spéculatifs ou avec le design critique
en fait le vrai glissement qui a eu
c'était non plus d'essayer de temps de
résoudre le problème que d'essayer de
trouver des moyens de le définir de
mettre en lumière et surtout de l'ouvrir
à la discussion
malgré tout et la dire malgré le fait
que c'est un domaine totalement
passionnant que c'est un domaine où tout
reste à faire donc les règles du jeu
sont à écrire il ya quand même pas mal
de défis qui se posent aux designers que
je suis à la fois des problèmes j'allais
le dire d'un professionnel est d'ordre
personnel parce que ça questionne aussi
mon éthique ma responsabilité et je
retiendrai trois grands défis le premier
c'était le trail au défi de la
légitimité parce que en tant que
designer ou encore quand même un déficit
d'image pas forcément les personnes et
plus crédit pour parler de la chose
publique ou dans les deux de la
démocratie le second problème c'est
celui de la responsabilité parce que en
tant que designer je peux pas me
permettre de faire les choses de mon
côté je suis obligé de m'entourer de
gens de croiser les opinions de
questionner qu'est ce qui fait que je
vais partir sur ce choix là plutôt que
sur un autre parce que ce que je fais en
tant que designer publica dispositif
démocratique que je peux concevoir sont
enfin du moins ont un impact sur vos
vies dans l'action de la vie donc il ya
la question de la responsabilité qui est
beaucoup plus forte que si j'avais
travaillé en agence ou sur des questions
économiques et le troisième défi qui
s'offre à moi et c'est peut-être le plus
pragmatique de tous c'est d'en vivre
parce que c'est pas très facile de
monétiser l'innovation démocratique de
faire en sorte que cette monétisation
reste indépendante pour que la solution
qu'on a apporté un problème un moment ou
un autre reste pérenne sinon le problème
va re surgir d'ici quelques mois
quelques années ou au mieux quelques
décennies mais il faut bien garder cette
indépendance pour pas être soumis au jeu
des influences
le point le plus important je dirais ce
qui a été en fil rouge au final de
toutes mes expérimentations de tous mes
travaux et c'est un peu la leçon que je
tire en tant que designer c'est que moi
en tant que faiseur ce qui est au final
le plus important c'est surtout de
mettre les autres en capacité de faire
et ne pas oublier merci